[Applause]
so last time you were here you were very
pregnant I was plus one yes yeah and
felt a little alone walking out this
time
no how are you sleeping too now right my
baby just turned two a few years ago
yeah thank you
we've been terrible twos but three major
is a real thing just for what I've heard
yeah but then again he turned two two
weeks ago and as I was leaving to come
here he was just like on the floor just
crying and I was like why are you I have
to go see Kelly Clarkson I'll be back
it's like I know they they lay it on
sometimes like why are you leaving
totally like blocking the threshold of
the door it's quite dramatic that means
that you were loved yeah he misses you
that's nice too he's an angel no he's
the best he's being mom's the best but
what have you learned about yourself
like since becoming a mom I mean uh
don't be too rigid in your plans because
anytime I try to hold on to like a
timing schedule nope it just it doesn't
work so I try to be you know go with the
flow you have to take everything as it
comes I try to you know get my sleep
where I can
um yeah when I was younger my mom would
always be like Emma I just need to sit
down and I'd be like I don't get it and
now I'm the one being like I just have
to sit down like I totally get the
sitting down thing 100 I always have to
plan my schedule like an hour in advance
so we actually make it on time that's
that's also 100 have to leave an hour
padding if if you make it at all yeah
right
I'm literally like I'm just not it's not
happening and I'm going to come up with
an excuse I'm like we're just not
getting out we're just not coming is the
thing it happens
um and so are you sleeping again like
I'm I'm sleeping again but you know I
wasn't obviously for the first year no
yeah and um and I just all I care about
now is sleep and making my sleep the
most luxurious possible so I'm like yes
eye mask bath face mask like everything
I can do to just cocoon myself to get
the best
four hours sleep now I know
it's a 5n um no it's so funny because
when I was younger I always felt like I
mean I could go like non-stop yeah I
wouldn't sleep for a date no I could let
either you sleep you go out you work you
don't care and now I'm like I only got
eight hours so yeah I'm praying I will
be a human you hate if I get less than
seven hours yes yeah totally 100 yeah it
will go downhill very fast
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
guys I'm going home